JAKE: Steve Gargiulo works with
people from all walks of life,
from all over the world, to help
them make their ideas happen.
His new book, "Surge, Your Guide
to Put Any Idea into Action"
provides the blueprint for how
to take more action on ideas,
sharing dozens of
stories, and distilling
proven instructional
design, social science,
and adult learning theories.
He loves, among many things,
Honest Tea, the movie
"Mrs. Doubtfire," and the
"Ghostbusters" theme song,
which is, you know,
that's interesting.
So let's give a warm
Google welcome to Steve.
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE: Awesome.
STEVE GARGUILO:
Thanks, Jake, cool.
Thank you all for
taking time out
of the day to be part of
this conversation today.
I want to talk for maybe
like 10 to 12 minutes.
And then we can have a
conversation from there,
because I think that's
more interesting.
So I want to start with
something that I love.
And I love Post It Notes.
So maybe a lot of you
spend a lot of time
using Post It Notes.
I feel like I spend a lot
of time using Post It Notes.
But they have a lot
of interesting uses
that maybe you're
not used to seeing.
So you can use them
to decorate an office.
You can use them as sunscreen.
You can use them for a
really kicking winter is
coming Game of Thrones party.
You could teach someone a
lesson who parked in a space
that maybe he shouldn't
have parked in.
And it turns out that apparently
you can even use them as cheese
if you're really in a bind.
So as someone who loves Post
It Notes, a few years ago
when I was at
South by Southwest,
I was walking around one
of the exhibition areas.
And 3M was there.
And they had these
really big Post
It Notes that they had
debuted, those ones that
are bigger than the
size of the human head.
And I had never
seen those before.
And they were giving
them away for free.
So I was, like, I want to get
a lot of these, like, a lot.
So I walked up, and I kind
of took a bunch of stacks.
And I'm walking with
my friend to a bar,
and we're figuring
out OK, what are
we going to do with all these
big Post It Notes that we just
acquired?
So we decided to just
write on one of these Post
It Notes, "free problem
solving, #zeroproblems.
And we're sitting at a
bar that's looking outside
into the street.
We just put the sign up, and
we started accosting people
as they walked down the street.
So we have our little, kind
of free problem solving stand.
And we're, like, hey,
whatever your problem is,
horseback riding,
welding, business, you
know, you name your problem.
We'll solve it for you.
And at first, there's a
couple of people, like,
does my shirt fit well?
We're, like, well,
you could do this.
Or someone is, like, can I
get a light bulb for this?
And we found a light bulb.
But then, all of a sudden,
this big line started forming.
And there's this
girl who's, like,
can I solve problems with you?
And it's, like, so then she's
solving problems with us.
We had an intern who was getting
people a couple of blocks down.
All of a sudden, the
big South By accounts,
like this Shit I Saw at South
by Southwest is a big account,
and so it turns into this
whole thing of all these people
who are coming getting
their problems solved.
This woman, who it turns out,
she's an executive of Goodwill,
she's how can we grow our brand.
It's, like, you have,
like, 500 stores.
How could you not
grow your brand?
At one store,
triple your prices.
At one store, offer
gift wrapping.
At one store, have
a co-working space.
She's, like, writing
down all of these things.
She's, like, can you come
and give us more ideas?
It's, like, I just
gave you 10 ideas.
Go do those, and then
maybe we can talk.
But one of the crazy things that
I learned from this experience,
and there was a lot
of crazy things.
We actually left.
The thing kept going.
It turned into a whole,
kind of big thing.
But one of the things I
learned from that experience
is that people seem to
value collecting good ideas
more than they do actually
making any of them happen,
right?
And we're all guilty of
this from time to time.
We have those ideas
that we're collecting.
We're collecting those
really good ideas
in the back of our heads.
But sometimes it can be really
hard to make them happen.
And so I think one
of the things that
made something like this happen
was the fact that we're just,
like, hey, we've got
some Post It Notes.
Let's just try something.
And we had that
bias towards action,
as opposed to the first
thing being, let's
talk about what we could do, or
let's brainstorm, or let's use
the Post It Notes to
come up with ideas
for things we could do.
It's, like, we just
started doing something
with that bias towards action,
where the first step can
be action, and then you think
about from there kind of what
comes next.
You know, I spend a lot
of time, unfortunately,
in rooms like this with
a ton of Post It Notes.
Who's been in rooms
like this before, right?
But who's been in a room like
this, and then a week later,
you wonder what the
hell ever happened
to any of those things?
Look how many Post It Notes.
What happened to any
of those Post It Notes?
What happened to
any of those things?
And so it's a real problem,
us not having that bias
towards action.
But it's something that
we can do something about.
So this idea of a
surge and what we
define in the book is, like
Jake said, one of the things
that I've spent a lot of time
in is in the Ted community.
And so as a Ted
organizer and speaker,
one of the things that happens
is you become this idea magnet.
And all these people
come in to you,
talking to you about their
ideas, which is great.
But over time, I
realized so few people,
like in many of these
examples, so few people
were taking action on them.
And so I started to study
the science of action.
So working with psychologists,
sociologists, anthropologists,
drill sergeants, what are
those important things?
And one of the most
important things
is taking that surge
of action right away.
Because most of the time, what
happens when you have an idea
is this top bar, right?
You have this new idea.
And then maybe
slowly, over time,
you slowly start to make
a little bit of progress.
But the most important
thing, if you really
want to see an idea happen
is take a surge of action
right away.
And the first step should be
action and doing something,
and that's how you start
to create the momentum
and get on a roll to actually
make something happen,
to actually bring an
idea into reality.
I want to tell a couple
of stories from the book.
So the book is filled
mostly with what
I think are fairly funny
stories, because they're
very relatable.
Because they're
the kind of things
that make you go I should
have done that or I
could do that with eight
million different things.
OK, so one starts with these
pink flamingo pool rafts.
Who's ever been on one of these?
Or one starts with these, excuse
me, white dove pool rafts.
Who's ever been at a pool
party with one of these?
They're pretty cool.
So a few years
ago, there's a guy
who's at a pool party with
these white dove pool rafts.
And he's, like,
wouldn't it be cool
if there's a pink
flamingo version of these?
So he googles it, and at
the time, there wasn't one.
And most people would just
kind of leave it there.
But he decides, you know what?
Let me just google
China manufacturer.
He finds a phone number.
He gets on it.
He's, like, hey, China.
I want a pink flamingo raft.
I want it to look like this,
whatever, blah, blah, blah.
Eight weeks later, it
shows up at his house.
He has a pool party with
his pink flamingo pool raft.
Everybody loves it.
He starts GiantFlamingo.com.
This guy has made over
six figures selling
these pink flamingo pool rafts.
Because in that moment,
he didn't just say,
this would be a cool
thing to do someday.
It was, like, what is that
first step I can take?
Yeah, I could find a phone
number, and call a guy,
and have one show up,
and see what happens.
And then things started
to snowball from there.
OK, another story--
so when the App Store
started to get big, 2008,
2009, everybody's making apps.
Everyone wants to make an app.
Has to have an app.
What's your app?
Got to have an app.
And there's a guy who's,
like, all right, I
want to have an app.
Everybody has an app.
I have no ideas for any apps.
But what I can do is, I
can look in the App Store
and say, what is the most
downloaded, lowest rated app?
So what is the one that people
want the most, but it sucks.
Well, it turns out it
was the Spanish Bible.
Like the only Spanish Bible
app crashed all the time.
It was really bad.
But people want a Spanish Bible.
So he's, like, well,
the Bible is free.
The Bible content's
just out there.
He's, like, I can hire someone
to make a Spanish Bible app.
He makes a new
Spanish Bible app.
Makes a ton of money
on this Spanish Bible
app just because he
put it out there,
because he had that idea.
Give you one other
example, there's
a woman-- when FBA came
out, Fulfillment by Amazon.
Great, where you can just
basically send them stuff,
it counts as their listing.
They fulfill the
orders, all that.
So when that started to get
big, maybe two years back,
there was a woman who was, like,
I want to use this service.
I got to figure
out what I can do.
I know I can make
some money on this.
She decided if I go
to Target every week,
the Target in my hometown,
they have a clearance rack
that's filled with all brand
new products-- like a vacuum
cleaner, a spatula,
all this stuff.
It's new.
It's not used.
It's got the label,
it's perfectly good.
She'd buy everything
on the clearance rack,
put it in a box,
send it to Amazon.
Amazon lists it, fulfills
the orders, all this stuff.
She makes six figures a year
buying stuff on the clearance
rack, driving to FedEx,
putting it in the box,
sending it to Amazon,
and spending the rest
of her life just hanging out.
OK?
But because she had that
bias towards action to do it.
And there's millions of
these kinds of stories,
and they're not all
about money, right?
They can be things
like activism.
There's this woman
in Tunisia who
wanted to preserve the Star
Wars set, the original Star
Wars set from the
original Star Wars movie.
And as opposed to just
thinking about it,
started this campaign.
It turned into this whole thing.
But there's a lot that we
can learn from those stories
to think, like, of course,
I see myself in this.
And there's the idea that I
have in the back of my head
right now, I can work
to make that happen.
So a couple of the lessons
that I think are important,
just to kind of wrap
this up, is that one
is that action is a muscle.
So just like some people
exercise their biceps, not me,
but some people, you can
exercise your action muscle.
And it's a matter of
working to say, OK,
anytime I have an
idea, what is action
that I can take right away?
And you start to
work that muscle,
and then you can start to
develop that action bias.
Another is we have to break
the tendency that is we
want to set aside time later.
Like we'll often
say, we build ideas
up to be so big in our head.
We have this great idea, it's,
like, I need to set aside a day
where I can bang that out.
I'm going to block my
calendar for Friday,
where I'm going to do that.
But you don't respect that time.
You don't protect that time.
You respect someone's meeting
that they put on your calendar
that you don't even
like that person.
But you prepped for their
meeting instead of your thing,
because you were
forced to in that.
But you can't force
yourself to do it.
You can't set aside
the time later.
You don't respect it.
Later never comes, right?
You have to work on
doing that sooner.
And then one of the biggest
things is when I have an idea,
it's often really
hard to come up
with actions for my own idea.
But when someone
else has an idea,
it's super easy to give that
person-- you could do this.
You could do this.
It's easier to fire off
actions for other people.
So the collaborative
nature is actually
super important for ideas.
And one of the things that
happened, when we have an idea,
it's not fully formed
yet, we're a little bit
embarrassed to share
it with other people
or to talk to other
people about it.
Because we feel like
it's not baked yet.
But the most important
thing you can do
is to have a conversation
with other people
about it, because they can
help you think about what
the actions are that you
could take right away to be
able to do something.
We all get caught
up in this game.
I was on a phone call last
week with a colleague who was,
like, we got to design a survey
to send out after this program.
What questions do you
think should be on it?
And they're talking for 20
minutes about-- well, because--
I'm, like, guys I just
sent out the survey.
I logged into Survey Monkey.
I built it while
we were talking.
We don't need to
over engineer this.
That bias towards
action is something
that you just need to
constantly check yourself on.
And it's really important.
And then the last thing
is everything in life
that's hard is just a series
of things that are easy.
So it just needs to
be broken down, right?
When we have these
ideas that are big,
I could have "write a
business plan for a company x"
on my calendar for six months.
And oh, I don't
want-- it's hard.
I don't know when
I'm going to do that.
That's really hard.
How do I get started?
But if it's just a matter
of breaking it down
to google business plan.
Read the first 10 articles.
Pick a template.
Fill out the first section of
the template, which is what
you would actually do anyway.
It's, like, oh, crap, like
I could have done that.
But when you build
it up in your head,
that's when you
get into trouble.
So everything in
life that's hard
is just a series of
things that are easy.
This is us.
That's me.
Happy to answer
questions and have
a conversation about action.
So what-- or do you want to
start things up a little bit?
JAKE: Let's hear
it, up for Steve.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE GARGUILO: Cool, thanks.
JAKE: We're both
super tall guys.
So we're going to just get a
little bit more intimate here.
STEVE GARGUILO: Cool.
JAKE: And we hope you've all
brought your live questions
and your ideas.
Steve is excited to hear them.
I figured we could start off
with a softball question.
STEVE GARGUILO: All right.
JAKE: Steve is a huge traveler.
He's been to over 100 countries.
STEVE GARGUILO:
I thought we were
going to talk about softball.
JAKE: I haven't asked it yet.
What is your most
underrated travel tip?
And what is your most
overrated travel tip?
STEVE GARGUILO: Hm.
So I think probably underrated,
actually, is hotels.
And not staying in hotels--
I mean, sometimes hotels,
sometimes Airbnbs.
But you can use
hotels that you're not
staying in for so many things.
Like, a hotel is
your [INAUDIBLE]----
you need an envelope, walk
to a hotel, find an envelope.
Any Doubletree Hotel in
the world, you walk in,
you can have a cookie.
You want to go swimming?
Walk into a hotel
and go swimming.
You want to find a bathroom?
You need to print your
boarding pass when you're
staying in an Airbnb,
walk into a hotel and say,
can I print my boarding pass?
I think you can use hotels
as your personal service
very easily when traveling.
JAKE: Cool.
OK, I have a bunch
of questions here.
But does anyone have
any live questions
for Steve about ideas
you're thinking about?
And you'll have
time to-- oh, sure.
AUDIENCE: So this isn't
an idea that I have.
But just the whole idea of what
you said earlier, about a surge
in action, and that's sort of
how you move things forward.
What about just sustaining
that motivation,
sustaining things even past
that surge, any recommendations
there?
STEVE GARGUILO:
So accountability
is super important, right?
Because we all have
things we want to do.
And it's, like, how do you
hold yourself accountable?
Everybody has different things
that work right for them.
And so knowing yourself
is also really important.
One of the reasons,
often times, you're
more accountable to someone
else's meeting than your own
is because you have that guilt
feeling of there's somebody
else involved.
So I think getting other
people involved really helps,
so having an
accountability buddy.
I have different friends
who I do something
I call accountability
days with, where we'll
block out two days together.
I would say, great,
the first day, we're
going to be 100%
focused on your stuff,
but I'm going to
be at your service.
So you want to help
make a website?
You want to help do this?
I'm going to be working for you.
The second day, we're
100% focused on my stuff.
And you're going to
be helping me out.
And I find that over the
course of those two days,
I'll get way more done.
Even though I'm only
spending one day on me,
I get way more done
than if I spend two days
by myself trying to work.
And there are a lot
of ways that you
can use people to hold yourself
accountable with accountability
check ins, and tools
and things like that.
So I think the biggest
thing is knowing
what is it for me
that's the hang up,
and then how do you combat that.
In some languages,
there's actually
two words for what we would
think of as procrastination.
So there's the classic
definition of procrastination,
which is, I know what I need
to do, but I'm not doing it.
And then there's this
definition of procrastination,
which is I actually don't really
know what I need to do yet.
I'm letting it be
on the slow burn.
I'm letting it simmer
in my subconscious
while I do other stuff
so I can come back to it
and work on it later.
We're really good at
tricking ourselves
into thinking it's the latter.
That, like, I don't know
what I need to do yet.
I'm letting it simmer.
When the reality is, more often
than not, it's the former.
And you actually know
exactly what you need to do.
It's just a matter of doing it.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
JAKE: I think one in the
back, and then we'll get you.
AUDIENCE: OK, so that's
very interesting,
the idea of pairing up
with somebody else to take
turns, what the
other person's doing,
what the other person's doing.
So it sounds like it would
be very good for people
with complementary strengths.
So what are some
examples of what
you've been able to
contribute to that
specifically versus
what the other person
has been able to contribute?
STEVE GARGUILO:
Yeah, a lot of times
it's not even necessarily based
on complementary strengths.
Because, yeah, I could
see, for example, OK,
I want to get a website done.
Yeah, I'm partnering
with somebody
who knows what she's doing and
helping me make the website.
But oftentimes it can be
for a simple thing, which
is, no, I just need to sit down
and finish writing this copy.
I need to sit down and
actually write down
what are some jobs that
I want to apply to.
I need to sit down and write--
honestly, I think
it's better for things
that you could do yourself.
But having somebody else
in the room helping you
makes it better and makes
sure that you actually do it.
So it could be the simplest
thing on your to do list.
But you're bringing someone
else in to help make it happen.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Was there a specific moment
where you realized, hey,
I should stop procrastinating
and should start taking action?
And if so, what was that moment?
STEVE GARGUILO: So
everyone in the world
is their own biggest hypocrite
and everything, too, right?
So I would be lying to say I'm
not procrastinating on things,
you know, right now as well.
So I don't think there's
any given moment where
every person could
cross a threshold
and they never
procrastinate again.
I think it's a matter
of being aware of it
and being intentional about
understanding that, like, OK,
I am procrastinating right now.
And I know what I could be
doing or should be doing,
and I'm not doing it.
Where we trick ourselves
is the "I don't know what
I should be doing right now."
If you take-- what I do
is, in any given situation
that's something that
seems hard, it's, like,
I take the five seconds
to think about--
Elon Musk talks a lot
about first principles
and these kinds
of things, right?
So you take the five
minutes to think about, OK,
why is this seeming hard?
What is the thing that
I could do right now?
I either need to collect
data on this to validate it.
I either need to take a first
step that kicks it to somebody
else to take another step on.
I either need to just
get over the fact
that my rough draft is going to
be horrible, so that I can then
give feedback to myself.
Whatever it is, it's like
what is that first thing that
can start the ball rolling?
Because it's the first
thing that trips us up.
We think the first thing
needs to be something else.
And if you ask yourself,
what is something
I could do to progress this?
That's the biggest thing that
starts to get you on the roll.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about something, like,
what if you're in a situation--
I wanted to get an investment
property for a while.
And I've been kind of
on the fence with it.
But there's certainly
a lot of downside risk.
So it's sort of
the kind of thing
that you don't just want to
take immediate action on it,
then find yourself
in a world or hurt.
What would you suggest for
how to go about something
that's a bigger thing that might
have a lot of downside risk?
STEVE GARGUILO: Right.
So I think the
first action then,
and that's a perfect
example of thinking
about what are the things that
I could start to do first?
So, for example, if I wanted
to start taking action
on that, could one of
the first things I do
be posting on Facebook, like,
hey, do any of my friends
have investment properties?
Could I chat with you?
Or going and actually
googling some articles
and starting to read
about it, and see
if that sets me down a path.
Or something that's
not just doing nothing,
which is what's super
easy, which is I
want to do that someday.
Or looking at,
like, OK, I'm going
to take three
examples of properties
to a friend who knows
about investments,
and just say, which of
these three would be better?
Or are all of these horrible?
Or actually doing something
that starts something?
I'm sorry for the
vague language.
But you know?
AUDIENCE: Thank you for the
presentation and the insights.
And what will be
your personal tips
for the personal
management tools,
like any apps or something
which you find really useful?
STEVE GARGUILO: Yeah.
It's a great question.
And I think it's one
of those things where
it's what works for you,
because we're all different.
Jake and I were actually
talking about tools that
can automate tasks for you.
So I love-- I use
Zapier a lot, which
is a tool that zaps data
between different tools.
Jake was telling me about--
JAKE: There's a software for
Mac called Keyboard Maestro.
And it will essentially automate
clicking, button clicking,
and downloading things.
And so if you have
any questions,
you can shoot me a question.
STEVE GARGUILO: Often when
people think about productivity
tools, they're thinking about
calendar tools and to do lists
and that kind of stuff,
which I find funny.
Because that to me
is not productivity.
Productivity is not
necessarily making a
to do list, though it could be.
Productivity is what
are the things that
are making me more efficient
and making me quicker,
so that at any
given moment it's,
like, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Things are happening.
So I like those kinds of things.
Or I like getting people
involved in things
so I know we're going to
make something happen,
so that I can just remove
it from my head altogether.
I don't have to put
it on a to do list
and think about it later.
I can just move it away.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for being here.
I feel we can all relate
to the million browser tabs
being open and having
a lot on our minds.
And you just spoke
about productivity.
I just want to hear a bit more.
How do you laser
in on that focus?
Because I do think a
lot of us in the room
are here because we
have a lot of ideas,
maybe an overwhelming
number of ideas.
But how do you sift through
the bad from the good
and kind of get that focus?
Because I love the
idea of throwing the to
do list out the window.
Like, if you're
not doing it now,
maybe you should never do it.
How do you kind of--
do you have a mantra or
framework or anything else
you can expand on to help kind
of close all the browser tabs
and just be more focused?
STEVE GARGUILO: Yeah, and they
eat up a lot of resources.
I think the biggest thing
in this situation is the oh,
I have so many ideas.
I don't know what to do.
Pick one, do a
little bit on that.
I know, it's facetious.
But pick one.
If truly, every single one
of them would be great,
and there's no way to
distinguish between them.
And it's, like, oh,
there's so many.
I don't know how to pick.
Pick one randomly.
Write them, put them
in a hat, whatever.
Pick one.
Spend some time
working on it, and then
see, oh, this is great.
I'm going to keep
working on this.
Or no, I'm going to
do something else.
I don't buy the idea of I have
so many things, and I can't--
one, automatically,
we have ways that we
rank things in our head.
You know the one that
you're thinking about
before you go to bed.
The one you're thinking
about when you wake up.
So automatically,
something's going
to be bubbling up for you.
But if something doesn't,
then just pick one
and start working on it.
And the other good
point of this is
start working on it
doesn't mean I'm going
to put my life savings into it.
Start working on it doesn't
mean every night now
is working on this.
But it's what are
those actions that you
could start to take that
can get you more data, that
can get you more feedback,
that can get you to a place
where you know--
I want to start
investing more time.
And the beauty about
doing that is you
could actually do that for a
number of the different ideas.
When you start thinking about
it from the perspective of what
are those quick
things that I can do.
Maybe it's as simple as
register a domain name
and put up a Launchrock page
and see if there's interest.
And that's super simple to do.
I have something I talk about
that I call the idea tax, which
is that anytime I have an
idea, I register a domain name.
And then, I know a year
from now I'm going to get
reminded that I got to pay
another $15 in idea tax
for this idea that I
haven't done anything with.
And it's going to trigger
me to say, all right,
are you really going to
make GarlicBreadReviews.com
happen this year?
Or can let that one go?
So again, it's kind of
whatever it is for you.
But it needs to be what are the
little things I can start to do
that can set me down the path?
AUDIENCE: It's great.
I love the idea of investing
time, not financials
in the beginning.
Because it is.
Investing your time
is priceless, really.
So thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
thanks for your time.
Forgot my question.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: No, it'll come back.
So I like what you said about
things being hard sometimes.
As we get older,
we can say things
are hard if they're
difficult, but we also
have the experience of simpler
things to compare them to.
I have a young kid, and he
doesn't say things are hard.
He just says, I can't do this.
So do you have an
example of something
that you could tell a young kid?
I usually would say
it's not hard, it's new.
Because you haven't
seen this yet.
So maybe you have
a similar example
of what you can tell the
younger generation as
to how to take their ideas,
having a bias to action,
for things that aren't
necessarily hard,
but they just need--
STEVE GARGUILO: Yeah.
One of the best principals,
top principals in coaching
is just asking questions.
And oftentimes when you
ask people questions,
you realize that they
kind of trap themselves
in their own logic.
I think that actually
works really well for kids.
If a kid said to me,
that's not possible.
I would be, like, what
makes it not possible?
Like, help me to understand.
Try to get them talking
and extract them out of it,
and then they find themselves.
Because it's hard, I get wanting
to say, like, no, anything's
possible!
But you telling that
to someone doesn't
mean they're going to
do anything with it.
But if you can lead
them to that place,
then I think that's great.
And then, I think,
also exposing them
to all these different
things that are possible.
So they start to collect
those different-- you know,
life is just this relentless
pursuit of insight.
And so the more insights
from different places
that you're getting planted
in your brain, the more
possibilities that you
can see, the more synapses
are firing together.
JAKE: One in the back?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I have a lot of
ideas in my head.
And when I start
working on them,
I don't have a problem starting.
But completing them
is really hard for me.
And I think what happens
during the process
is that I kind of
sabotage myself,
thinking will it
really be successful?
Do I have the right network to
get to market with the idea?
Maybe I'll just do
it, and no one ever
sees it, things like that.
So all these doubts
start dropping in,
especially when the things
become larger and larger.
So how do you separate
the bias towards action
from the outcome?
How do you see those two things?
Are those separate?
STEVE GARGUILO: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
I think part of the
seeds of your question
that I probably
didn't quite answer
that I think is really good
is, like, OK, then if I go
and I do start all these
different things, that
can become super
overwhelming, where now I'm
taking action on all this.
And OK, what's going on?
So a couple of things
there, I think.
One is I do think the first
step on an idea is action.
At some point, you have
to make a decision on--
is this action
yielding the results
that I would want to
see for this idea, where
it should continue?
Or should I pause
that, put it away?
I think we don't do
a good job confirming
to ourselves that we're
done working on an idea.
Our actions say that we're
But we let ourselves
beat ourselves up
to say, oh, I should
still be working on that.
Versus taking stock and
saying should I still
be working on this, or am I
allowed to put that one away?
There's a great book
called "Essentialism"
which talks a lot about
that kind of stuff.
One of the exercises
in that book,
which I like doing personally
from time to time, maybe
every six months, is on Post
Its or little slips of paper,
like, what's everything
that I'm actively
spending time and energy
on in my life right now?
And that could be
projects, that could
be things related to family.
Like, what are things that
I'm actively spending time on?
And you have a ton of different
things in front of you.
And then, it's which
of these are essential?
And which are the ones that
I want to be spending time,
and which are the ones
that it's time to put away?
And sometimes we don't
officially put an idea to bed.
And so every now and then
that you think about it again,
oh, man, I haven't
done anything on that.
And you beat yourself up on it.
When in reality,
you can be, like,
I feel good about putting
that one to bed for now.
And I'm going to
focus on these things.
So I think that's an
important way to deal with it,
and then it doesn't
feel so overwhelming.
AUDIENCE: Right.
I guess the threshold that
I struggle with this, like,
maybe I'm deceiving myself into
thinking that this idea won't
go anywhere.
Just because, I guess,
there is the execution part,
and then there is
the hustling part.
Just making the world aware
that this thing exists,
and maybe somebody
should use it.
But maybe I'm too lazy or
too inept in doing that.
And then I think my
idea isn't great,
and I just put that to
rest because it's not
going anywhere.
So that fork in the road
is really confusing for me.
STEVE GARGUILO: One
of the best ways
to maybe think about
those is how can I
start involving some more
perspectives in what's
currently a very hard thing for
me to figure out, this fork?
I don't know if, with
the ideas, you're
involved with other people,
or even if you take it
to someone who's not going
to be involved with it,
where you just want to bounce--
you know, hey, here's
what's happening.
What do you think?
The longer things
live in our head,
the longer nothing's
going to happen with it.
But as soon as we can vocalize
and talk to somebody about it,
even a person who can't
talk, can't emote,
can't do anything-- like
that blue thing in the back
of the room--
just saying something
to that actually
can help you think about,
oh, saying it out loud,
I changed this.
But then, assuming that that
thing is sentient and can
respond to you, it can give
you even more feedback.
So sometimes it's a matter
of get it out of your head,
write it down,
say it to someone.
And then you can
realize, OK, here's
how I can pick up the
pieces and move it forward.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
marketing tips for your ideas?
You mentioned if you have an
idea, create the landing page
and put it out there.
See if there's any interest.
Well, let's face it.
Nobody's just going to
show up on your website
unless you just find some people
to let them know about it.
Do you have any go to
testing, marketing things
that you do to [INAUDIBLE]?
STEVE GARGUILO: Yeah, question
on marketing tips and kind of
go to marketing things.
I mean obviously
using Google services
and products, I'm sure,
would help everyone.
I think it totally depends
on the idea, right?
Because if you're
trying to do something
and you're trying to create
some kind of campaign
or get a bunch of
hits on a video,
it's very different than
trying to sell a product.
So I don't exactly know
how to answer that.
For me--
AUDIENCE: It's a retail product.
STEVE GARGUILO: OK.
So for a retail product.
AUDIENCE: That you may
sell on Amazon or--
STEVE GARGUILO: Yeah.
So I think I'm
always a big believer
in the personal
aspects of anything.
So for me, it would be
involving my closest friends
in the story of it and
getting them jazzed about it
and having them going out on
my behalf, talking about that,
and kind of starting there.
And that gets to a little bit
of enough of a critical mass
where you could start to
get feedback and figure out,
is this something
that's catching on.
The other Marketing 101 thing
is just targeting enough.
I think even though
that's so obvious,
most people still feel
the products that they
make are for everyone.
But they're not.
The products they're making
are for a specific person,
and they don't take the
time to really define
that specific person.
And go work on, where
are the communities where
those specific people exist?
Am I a member of that community?
How am I contributing and
adding value in that community?
Have I garnered respect in
that community where I can even
sell something to that person?
Because selling to that person
is step 10 on that journey.
And if I think I'm just
going to put something up
and they're going to want it,
I haven't built the trust.
I don't have the permission,
all that kind of stuff.
I'm a big believer in Seth
Godin and tribes and communities
and this kind of stuff.
I think community building is,
like, the most important skill
set in the 21st century.
And so that's kind of how
I think about this stuff.
AUDIENCE: That's great.
Thank you.
JAKE: Cool.
Any other questions for Steve?
I've got a couple.
Let's see.
So you talk in your book
about divergent thinking
which is exploration
of possibilities
and then convergent thinking,
which is deciding what to do.
We talk a lot about
unconscious bias
in decision making at Google.
But we don't necessarily
think about bias--
and you spoke to
it some, like, how
we use bias towards
examining possibilities.
Like, what's possible
for me as an individual?
What's possible for my team?
And you've been exposed
to a lot of cultures
and a lot of different
company cultures.
Curious to get your
thoughts about what
are some biases people
have towards kind
of examining possibilities?
STEVE GARGUILO: Yeah.
I mean, in general, one
of the things that we
love doing in companies is
having committees and having
meetings where we explore
possibilities, right?
And all of those are
still hypotheticals.
And so the more we live in
hypotheticals, where we're
exploring and examining
what could be,
the less that we're spending
time in the what actually is.
So it goes back to
the point of, as
opposed to living
in the hypothetical,
if there's five ideas to
a given solution, what
are some things that
you could take action
on that could start to validate
them in the real world?
Whether that's through
a survey or a prototype
or a kind of whatever it
is that's making it real,
now we're having a legitimate
conversation versus an unknown.
I think, especially
at Google, I would
imagine every decision is a
very data driven decision.
And so the longer
something is hypothetical,
the less data you
could possibly have
towards helping you
make that decision.
So making it real, I think, is
the most important thing to do.
The other thing I would
say that, if you think
about the cultural aspect
is, I'm sure all of us
work on global teams on a
day to day basis, right?
A lot of what we've talked
about today, to many people,
is viewed as a very
American thing.
It's very American
to be action biased
and to be doing these
kinds of things.
And while I don't
agree with that,
the reality is, while
there is that perception,
then you're going to be
looked upon as the person
on the team who needs to
help drive that change.
If you're leading a
global team, and you
want to create more of
a bias towards action,
you need to go two inches more
for every inch you want to see
the rest of your team go.
And so the role modeling, I
think, is really important.
If you're thinking about
wanting to create more action
bias in your teams, then you
have to be doing it, too.
JAKE: Cool.
Any other live
questions for Steve?
All right, great.
Well, thank you all so much.
Thank you, Steve,
for being here.
Let's hear it one
more time for Steve.
[APPLAUSE]